tagged yourself I'm the penguin walking
into the barrier he's persistent
but just a stupid I exploded over
already you started the game it
automatically starts hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to can't
drive this with Schad lead say hi and
then blow me up again what is up guys
the girls it's a short leash and today
we're playing catering the same yeah
immediate boom let's click rematch and
see if we can get this [ __ ] better you
didn't say hi to my guys though hi
there we go I don't allow no intros here
good let's it's mine but alright go how
do I do this click rematch ok
no rematch are we competing or something
now we're working together
ok I'm going I'm going
this is great it's going wonderfully
going beautifully what the hell is this
oh my god yeah please wait bad please
play something oh my god oh my god so I
got this look at the ground ok it's
stuck in the ground
I like it up yeah it did happen and then
I died again but not bad not bad
ok wait give me another go and then also
and they did yes so the basic principle
of this game is I'm driving and shot
leech he is placing the track as we go
so you can see his perspective on the
right and then my perspective on the
left is I'm driving my bus and I'm just
going oh so friendly oh you how fast
your keys might be when it countdown the
Baltimore is the white among the shares
Oh bollocks bollocks
alright let me try to build I'm gonna
blow you out of the water alright I
realize it's gonna work
alright we clips which never got click
rematch and right quick is to try I
don't know and you don't even need to
tell me how to do doesn't go well ok I
think I know what happened I forgot to
say that for
remote so I'm searching the WASD right
okay sure okay go for it so I'm assuming
I got to get to that tile over way
yonder way right the one with the trees
on it
yeah but that's just a area that is
there more or less you just go as far as
you can okay I'm ready okay go go go go
go go go go go go just going cricket oh
my god go oh oh
why'd you go the one way I didn't build
because I was in the air on fire alright
fine one more go give me this one now I
by the way over another I'm building
he's driving it's confusing but it'll
make sense oh hopefully that's work oh
ah wait I'm driving why am i driving
wait I didn't buy I think we have to
switch first alright fine the invites
automatically fine fine fine I'm ready
okay what's good all right
flap flap flap flap whoa I don't think
is exactly easy the drug yeah okay mine
seemed fine I don't know what's wrong
with you
oh boy it's a zoom buggy it's not
exactly ah I didn't see which way you
were going there I didn't have much
control where I was going right right
well why is it hard to drive I think the
doom buggies just hard to steer best
fast gotcha
playa bottom left is the speed bird
driver oh don't go that way
those oh god I made I'm sorry it's got
all kinds of bogged up can you even go
that way oh god you can't hang on quick
whew okay we're making it oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh no oh what what
happened but I was pretty good and I
just noticed that there's good be near
misses airtime boost timer this game's
gonna be good once it gets to the face
it's already pretty good I gotta like it
yeah
all right you go you go skadoodle II do
so quick hit on him oh that ah I
misheard you
Oh God I don't know what to take
everywhere murderer
Oh No Oh God I'm gonna put you off hang
on keep going
you're leaving me I'm out of tiles I
have no time I was left yeah I have to
land on those soils and work let me see
if I can actually go above one you make
it fast enough maybe it will work all
right
I believe in you uh uh Oh Frieda Hey
nope great quick is there turn the tile
okay uh uh oh yeah
turn tiles you said that was the thing
that I needed to yeah okay
yeah what food all right I got this hang
on you you you don't have much faith in
me but I have a lot of faith in me and
I'm pretty sure I know I got gold what
I'm doing here of course watch out for
the wrecking ball I'm ready
oh all right you want me to try and
drive sure all right okay all right all
right here we go I'm so ready I don't
think you should be believing me and
believing it so what else can I do but
believe in you I'm literally driving
blind here there is no road in front of
me therefore I have to believe in you at
some point
okay all right we're fine I'm just
getting out ah I can't let it once the
bus stops is like I can't turn around
fast enough to pick up any speed because
what is option 1 different vehicle no no
no no I'm sticking with the bus I gotta
go with the bus or else yo there's no
point in any of this true and I love
your hat thank you I got the mustache
too so it's all good oh nice nice nice
nice nice twice is nice that's the wrong
direction otherwise every was going to
turn that direction I did not assume
that all right actually I'll give you
one more try and then I go back to
building okay it's always those turtle
ones that I have to be turned that
seemed to be dick all right I'm going to
try to keep an eye on what you're
building
so that I know delightfully e-e-e-e is
kind of got stuck I did not know you can
you can like call out which direction
you're going to go but it's too late my
turn to build watch as a pro tells you
how to do this yeah watch has the pros
who's never played this system for today
okay don't worry about us be really
previous some real art left turn in
coming up ahead rotating no that didn't
rotate jump over it what jump over it
jump over it yeah you did I made all
right dude making power everyone great
obstacle narrow road straight ahead
don't get bashed keep going diverging
path it will help this sugar that's the
water yeah I'm going over what where are
you oh god you're dead I was pretty good
that was pretty good not bad that was
pretty good yeah yeah okay this time I
got it working in bedrock I think we're
we're absolutely getting better I think
I'm getting better this I don't know
what you're doing over there but I'm
carrying you okay so there with old my
pole yeah thank you for agreeing okay
right turn right turn no no no let her
head left her lighter there right I'm
flying
okay hang on keep going come on
oh no you went left alright one more
girl ah choices are for losers anyway
you don't need choices you just need to
victory I don't know all right left turn
incoming scrubbers or Ford they make all
your decisions for you
is that how it works okay go straight
ahead wibblewobble
bricklaying thing you're going to have a
right turn up ahead then you're going to
go straight again after that oh you're
in the drink how do you keep getting in
the water how are you going to wait are
you getting in the water I remember in
the world a time I just a little bit to
slip right okay look to me like you were
in the water
okay yeah just to just one person that
was term travel I kept me going for us
my vehicle left art and slow down oh
sorry sorry sorry okay go over it make
it forward you got it you're doing great
keep going yeah keep going
this is going keep going we keep going
we have this keep going yes you can
still place underneath me to save me oh
I could I didn't even think about that
yeah one one last try one last go this
what am i yep all right or forward for
left turn incoming okay uh-oh trying to
get you back to straight oh that's weird
oh that's okay I got you okay flame 800
keep going keep going you got this yeah
like a windmill coming up it's a boy
whoa yeah get you oh I got you why I had
you the wheel blocked me ah
hey that was a high score that's not
what that's not bad
alright this is becoming amazing we
bought it for twenty four seconds that
was pretty good you want to go one more
time yes okay you better at listening
see how the turtle mechanic kind of gets
a little bit confusing on some it does
it does left-turning coming back to a
straight keep going forward
you got another turn up coming let's see
uh Oh shooty where you going here full
boy keep going this go ahead go bail
bonds oh where you going
alright keep going keep going okay oh no
that's not right hang on oh that yes
okay you're doing fine hold on oh it's
bright but that was I'm sorry it's fine
can you go through there oh we have four
they are don't worry a new high school
or not bad not bad
I think that's a good point in this
episode that was pretty cool thank you
so much for joining you on this one
everyone please check out shad Leach in
the description below and anything else
I say love tears bupkis excellent
closing words so thank you everybody if
you want to see this get let us know
down in the comments below as always we
will see you in the next video bye
[Music]